tom the main reason we contacted you not
to see your great kazoo t-shirt or watch
your image freeze up or have you make us
wait 15 seconds before you say something
we need to know your reaction to the
news that cam newton is the starting
quarterback even though they haven't
announced it they made the guy a captain
so it's pretty damn clear he's going to
be the starting quarterback
yeah as peter griffin said
oh my god who the hell even cares
it's been obvious for like two and a
half weeks that he was going to be the
starter i mean if he wasn't the starter
and he was taking twice the reps of
brian hoyer and jared stidham that would
be coaching malpractice in my estimation
um he really won the job though and i
think it's interesting
in that you see a guy from a distance
shireen and
you think he's one way and you wonder
about his authenticity
and
how he's packaged
you know and branded and then you see
him on the regular out of practice and
how authentic and consistent and
um real he is and you can see why
he does have the gravitational pull
that he actually does have and that's
what we've seen from cam newton that's
why i'm not surprised he was also named
st uh captain in addition to starter
yeah i was gonna ask that tom were you
surprised that he was a captain and the
fact that he's only been there since
july i think he signed july 8th or
whatever it was so he hasn't been around
those teammates very long and i know
it's traditional that the quarterback
gets to become the captain i mean brady
was what an 18-time captain or something
like that
but still the fact that he was only
around his teammates a short period of
time that didn't surprise you at all
that he was named a captain
yeah i think a little bit that it you
know the news that he was
but the way bill belichick is it's
really interesting psychologically
mike lombardi once said there's two
different ways to motivate a guy and one
is through money and the other is
through responsibility and bill
belichick has done that through the
years gerard mayo is a second year
player named the captain and sent out as
the only guy to take
uh the coin flip and that's a team in
2008
in 2009 that you know really needed
leadership he's done it with devin
mccourty
the more leadership responsibility he
keeps on guys
the more buy-in he seems to get from
them so i think it's it's a fascinating
psychological
ploy that he understands that look cam i
know we're paying you a million dollars
but that's just
bookkeeping who cares you got 100
million dollar contract you signed
five years ago let's just make it a
captain of a very good team and let's
see what we can do here and i think that
stuff
can actually work
and tom you know i look at the outcome
of the player vote and we know from past
experience that it doesn't matter who
votes its matter it what matters is who
counts the votes so and not that i'm
disputing that the players voted
legitimately and fairly and squarely cam
newton a captain but it does have a
psychological impact and i feel like
that bill belichick has been
going out of his way
to boost cam newton he had the radio
interview earlier this week where he
said nobody works harder than cam newton
and you know is this part of the effort
to push the buttons on cam newton or has
bill belichick learned from all the
things that rankled tom brady that you
can't withhold praise for 20 years at
some point you have to go out and throw
a bouquet in the general direction of a
guy who is getting the job done right
for you yeah and i think the interesting
thing
you know
that belichick would say as it relates
to brady is i said plenty of things over
20 years about tom
you know the no quarterback i'd rather
have and um you know tom works as hard
as anyone takes care of himself but they
were always kind of platitudes so they
were wrapped
in
generalities
this with cam was just so flowing and
over the top in that you know he finds
what he's not good at and works on and
none of us are good at doing that but
cam does that
i think it is specific to the motivation
of different players because belichick
understood
early on that brady responded to it and
i think in the latter half of his career
um
there was a weariness from belichick
about a brady that he perceived to be a
changing brady
which you should change as you go from
25 to 35 to 40.
and
brady's motivations were different and
it didn't really play the same it wore
his ass out
he still responded to it but it had long
since
gone from being wow yeah i gotta go
prove it to bill he was proving it for
himself and his teammates
during the last five years
one more for you on cam newton because
there's other patriots issues we want to
get to
the cam newton that i saw those years in
carolina on the days that things are
going well you can see it you can sense
it the demeanor is very positive the big
smile the superman gesture giving the
balls to the kids in the stands after he
scores a touchdown but there were those
days where it just wasn't going their
way and all too often you kind of see a
dejected cam newton like how much are
they working on getting cam
to not throw in the towel if they happen
to be down oh i don't know 28 to 3 in
the second half of a super bowl you know
to get that mentality in place where
even if it doesn't feel like your day it
can become your day any given drive any
given play any given throw
i don't know how hard they're working on
that because it would be presuming that
he's not good at doing it i think they'd
have to see it first now one thing that
josh mcdaniels i think is excellent at
is
maintaining positivity
cam
has to be a leader because
it is a
wide receiver and tight end room so
void of
experienced talented players i mean you
have julian edelman
and then you have two rookie tight ends
and you have a converted corner from
bemidji state and gunner olshewski and
you have uh
kind of a
up and down perhaps maybe good perhaps
maybe horrible
first rounder in nikhil harry and
undrafted jacoby myers and damir byrd
who's a you know mid-tier free agent
signing so
he can't go in the tank
he has to be a guy
who
carries
the fortunes of the team and the
attitude of the offense
consistently at a high level
too so
that's a great question i don't know how
he'll be but they can't afford to have
that happen with him and yeah i think we
saw it last year with brady when when
there were times where he'd be
a little morose kicking rocks now his
the aspect of that to him shireen and
mike was
that he was fatigued like i know how
it's going to look when the season
starts you haven't done anything oh
let's go get antonio brown right before
the season begins because we know that
we were insufficiently prepared and then
that blows up too
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports